Hello, nothing happened.
I just want to get, hello everybody.
I'm so ready.
Hello, everyone.
Hello, hello, everybody, and welcome to Girls Frontline 2X.
Um, but yes, uh, for those who don't know what Girls Frontline Exilium is, it is the official sequel of the first mobile game Girls Frontline, and it is a new 3D strategy RPG for, so but, and for those who don't know, you can actually download it right now on your mobile devices and PC.
You can see the link pinned in the chat, and also in the description.
me fix this real quick i know chat is dead so let me get that in here so you guys can be less dead because i would had i thought i was i had everything like out um out and out for like three hours by the way like two hours i set everything up i was like i'm ready and i was like wait you're alive everyone you're alive anyway a huge shout out girls front line too for the sponsor because for those who don't know they have a new patch out right now so they contacted asked me to check it out with you guys so yes the commander is back ready to lead a new line of dolls so yeah also for those who don't know if you use the link to download the game there's a lot of free rewards and we all know we love free stuff So,
for the free rewards, I believe you can get 34 free pulls if you're a returning player.
So their signing event has 10 pulls.
And there's like event resources that are like equivalent to like 24 pulls.
But if you are a new player, you get 120 pulls.
So yes, that is a lot of stuff you can get from that.
Yeah, I know.
I love free stuff.
We all love free stuff.
bunch of new things to look forward to or the you're too old to be playing with nobody is too old to be playing with dolls uh but there is a lot of stuff going in um with the new patch and uh i'm gonna see if i can go through all of it with you guys and i believe i think you guys already saw in the starting that uh there is a new doll her name is uh jan you uh who is a support doll and Apparently,
she's built around, like, electricity, like, an electric team, and, uh, and there's also, like, a new skin for her, as well as, I believe there's, like, a new outfit, too.
Let me double-check real quick.
I don't want to be like, there's a new outfit!
There's, like, you're pointing me.
Oh, no, not new outfit.
Returning outfit.
So, you can, there's a returning outfit that you can, um, you can get, I believe.
Yeah, so there's a lot of new things to look forward to, and then there's a new event as well.
So I'm really excited to come back to the girls' front line, especially the dormitory.
I think we all had a fun time in the dorms.
So for those who don't know, there are, I think this event goes from until now to October 15th, I believe.
like, I was going to say, how many days is that?
Like half a month.
You have like half a month to go to to get in on the new event, the new character, and all that stuff.
Yeah, so I'm very excited to try it all out.
I believe the event is called Intercise.
I can't pronounce.
I'm so bad at pronunciation.
Intercise of Reminiscence.
Okay, is that how you pronounce it?
Intercise intercease of reminiscence i'm trying i'm trying uh but there's yeah and there's also like oh yeah the new outfit was it the mozen negant outfit and you get 10 pulls with that as well so there's like i said there's so many things um there's a lot of stuff uh with this new event so i'm like i hope i can get through all of them in time uh all right all right of course to begin it's time to do the pause it's it's time all right i with my luck from yesterday i believe it can cross over here as well So,
I do want to say, I do want to, pull the lever, I do want to say that I want to thank Girl's Frontline for providing me an account, and that's why it's, that's why I have this much currency in there.
It's not because, like, that's why I'm allowed, I did not, I did not break my bank, I just need you guys to know I did not I I do not have a a problem so I do want to let you guys know that um this account was provided by Mika team so um so that's why I have that much currency in there uh this is a this is professional not an addiction anyway anyway all right i think i can get her in two tries i believe all right access 10 i think it's possible okay
oh oh oh oh it's already skipped it's orange i don't need to know the door back on her I was like no I know what you are door closed all right I just say in 10 tries really maybe I memorized the color I know what orange is the lower tier gold is where things happen oh well it's like oh bam go home return the sender leave take the plane away I don't care I just oh wait is that cheetah yeah see you guys I remember okay open it release I see her I'm like I'm like fly away I don't want you return return the sender all right okay within three tries i bet you i can get her
oh my god i just peeked through the hole okay within four tries guys within four tries
you did i did i creaked open it a tiny fit and i was like
that's all i need to know get out of here okay five tries within five tries okay you are i'll let the other girl i'll let the girl leave the chopper okay all right nope Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, you want to join my army?
Oh, oh, oh, all right.
I'll let her through.
It was just a gun.
I let her gun through.
Open the dad door.
It was just a gun.
I let the gun in my home.
There's no way.
What's Max Pity?
Guys, there's no way.
What's Max Pity, chat?
All right, six tries.
So nice of you to let the guns through, but send home the women.
Okay, 20.
There's no way we hit 26.
There's no way.
Six times the try.
Okay, as long as I get it within seven tries, I'll get it.
Right?
Oh.
That has to be it.
There she is.
That's not her.
That's just a gun.
Is
that her?
It's not even her!
Oh my god.
And she's eating out my fridge!
How are you hungry?
You're not real!
And she's gonna eat my food?
I lost.
I lost the 50s to 50s even better.
It's real to me.
How did she have hunger?
I thought they were like dolls.
Who gave you hunger as a train?
Who?
They said that.
Why can't I just charge her?
I just plug her on the socket.
I lost all the food.
foodie I love her already yeah but like how who programmed her to have taste buds well yes but who programmed her to have taste buds she's gonna eat me out of home your greed sickens me she does not need pizza i need pizza she does not whoever programmed her to have taste buds who is he they all do actually she's gonna she's gonna ruin me she's already eating everything i have in my fridge which is not a lot
Oh my god, I have like one what two more pulls before the pity hits
She can have pizza when she pays for the rent
Oh my god, I already let one I already let one doll in I'm not letting another oh it's only a gun.
That's fine I Alright
Check, if it resets, within two tries.
Everything resets, too.
It all guns.
Women, oh my god.
Oh, why did I let her through?
This is within two tries, guys.
It reset.
Who is she?
Wait, I think I got her before.
Oh, her head is like...
Um, it's like a bunny ears.
right it's a crawler but she's purple she's not good yeah she's like a cyber bunny cybernetic bunny all right skip it's just all guns oops all guns oh and uh wait is that a gun what is that how do you even shoot this oh yeah i was gonna say it's cheap what that looks cheap as hell all right we've been three tries
All right.
Center back.
What if I just quit game?
If I just quit game, we'll never know who I got.
It'll be a surprise for all of us.
Please, please give me a...
Give me a...
please oh my god wait oh this is like serotonin this has to be her right I swear if it gives me Sabrina again I swear to God this has to be this has to be Tian Yu right it has to be her stop oh oh oh is it her what if I just what if I right click If anyone's close to game,
we'll never know if it's her.
It's not her!
Oh, Erpo first.
Oh, she's Erpo.
Oh, thank God.
I was like, who is she?
Latara.
Oh, this has to be her.
This has to be her.
She sounds like she knows Kung Fu.
Wait, it is!
I did!
within three tries guys it's jam you I knew it I knew I could get it within three tries stability damage map wide buffs and assists yes he only three tries she's got hands she don't need no gun you should be lucky if she does use her gun no three tries because it resets so everything resets as well yay she has her own i believe that's her special weapon right leaping tiger oh also there's springfield too so if you guys didn't know this is a rerun of the doll that you could get as well so this is springfield and then there's new gun for yeah we might as well just grab it as well i mean it'll be pretty what if i just give her like the cheapest gun
I just give her that Oh my god What if she, never mind, you don't get your gun Wait, how do I Refitting room?
Alright, where is she?
Tian Yu, also if you guys didn't know I think one of my favorite parts about this is that There's an affinity There's an affinity thing you can do with it So you could get married I don't get divorced I remember, like, I think, like, the person, the one,
the, whoever was on this before, like, married, like, a few of them.
I was like, I was like, damn!
Oh, there she is.
All right.
Where is...
How do I equip?
Wait, I remember how to equip her gun.
I'm going to give you your worst, a worst gun possible.
A few sounds like rookie numbers.
Alright, don't worry.
I got you.
I don't have your weapon.
Not because I didn't want to pull for it.
But I think it'd be really funny.
Alright.
Oh my god.
How many do I have?
It doesn't stop.
There you go.
Oh.
Alright, there you go.
Okay, is that, like, grayed?
Yeah, gray.
Here you go.
You get whatever this gun is that apparently I have.
I, like, have my own little...
My own little gun harem right here.
Alright, you get the retired gun.
Alright, now I'll pull for your weapon.
But it doesn't mean you'll get it.
I'm pulling it so that I can look at it.
You have my own...
I actually have my own armor.
I'm only pulling for it so I can put it on as display.
She doesn't actually get it.
Yeah, I'm a distributor.
Oh, oh my god.
Whose gun is this?
All right, get out of here.
I want to pull...
I want her to hold this.
Is this like...
Is this locked to a character?
Yeah, that's it.
an armory is technically a gun harem.
It's just like, it's already like, oh, I want to give her that.
I think that one's silly.
No way, I kept more clothes.
Handgun users only.
Jenny, why can't you be a, why can't you be both?
Alright, this has to be it.
Oh my god, it is.
I was just coping.
Alright.
Retired model alpha.
Wait, that doesn't look like.
This doesn't look like Leaping Tiger.
What is this?
The Samosek.
What the heck is this?
This doesn't look like... This doesn't look like Leaping Tiger.
Where's the Tiger?
I fell the 75-25.
I used up all my luck.
I really did.
I knew when I woke up late today, when I when I slept past poor alarms, I knew today was not not the day I just for today and also the rest of the week yeah I slept through four alarms I like turn off the alarm while I was it's like I have no recollection of even like turning my alarms off it's okay it reset itself so technically we can get it in two tries it the entire thing is reset oh my god are you serious
this time this is it
no it's because like i i put my i think i put my phone way too close to my bed are you serious come on give me i get a sword why is there a sword that's so weird that's i get a freaking sword i'm like i'm This is a gun armory.
Why is there a sword in here?
That sword doesn't go pew pew.
It's so bad.
Why is there a sword in my gun game?
When does sword go pew pew?
I can't...
If you throw it, it's technically a gun.
Oh, you're right.
Oh my gosh.
I've already lost count.
I've lost count.
Not with that attitude.
Swoosh, swoosh.
Oh, let's have a sword that just shoots mini-swords out.
Please.
Send it back.
It shouldn't even leave my playing.
Okay, when is hard pity?
Oh, not now.
Not today.
No hard pity today.
wait that has to be it's red tigers are red yeah we did it i was like wait where's the tiger no this is not hard pity it reset itself it's like this has to be i don't i i'm red equals tiger tigers are red you know what i feel so lucky today that I that I feel like I can pull her too you know what?
Free let's do it I feel like I can pull her too it's possible see I never hit hard pity I've never hit hard pity so like that means I'm lucky
alright two tries it'll work I swear to god oh
my god i swear to god this time this time i already have her but i don't care it's about sending a message now i already have her but that doesn't matter to me i want it all who is she oh cassinia a dollar an unusual obsession with making my oh okay i like her she's a hard worker She's gonna make me money
All right, here we go This should be it.
Nope
Wait, is that the same person?
Sounds like money person that sounds like something who wants money
Again, I just got you I literally just got you That's okay, she'll make me money, right?
She's not gonna Seal from under me, right?
Okay, this time.
This is it.
This is my first time pulling for her.
Wait, why would she take my money?
When she won't- If she loves money so much, she should make me money.
Like, what is she gonna do with money?
She doesn't have free will.
Wait, wait.
have do dolls have bank accounts oh wait that has to be her
why do you have bank accounts they work for me oh
it's not stealing they work for me didn't I like aren't they like Like, literally, I care for them and everything.
Oh, wait, there it is.
This has to be her.
I just rest.
She is purple.
She's not good.
That does not look like her.
Wait, I got it from last match!
How do I lose?
Did I lose another 50-50?
I'm just saying, I pay for the rent.
Like, do they pay for the rent?
I literally house them.
I give them gifts.
I give them clothes.
I give them guns.
So why do they have their own?
Do I give them an allowance as well?
I pay them.
I'm yeah, I'm going for the completion rate now.
I also give them an allowance.
I'm not even a commander anymore.
I'm just a dad.
A dad with, like, so many children.
Or maybe just, like, they're all just my girlfriends, I guess.
Oh, she's cute.
I like her.
What's her name?
I like her little...
headband.
I think that's really cute.
I'm going broke with all these girlfriends.
Now you're thinking.
I like her.
I like her little headband thing.
Her headband design is really cute.
Alright, this time.
I don't understand.
Why don't they want to live with me?
I offer so much.
You literally get allowance free like free accommodations free food like i have it all
and i only employ like what how many per per fight so like 90 of the girls don't even have to do anything i'm a great employer why don't they want to work for me I provide everything Yeah, I might have a little gambling addiction, but like But like it's just a little this has to be here come home come home spring I already have you,
but come back home I want two of you
What I want two of you in my hair That has to be here
Two springfields.
Yeah, that's her.
Yay!
We did it!
Oh, she's a sniper.
Why is she so close?
Oh, I like her outfit.
Oh, wait, she has like little knee, like, thigh guards?
Yeah, guard those thighs.
They're dangerous.
Oh, it's like a little bird robot too.
a sniper but she heals oh like does her bullet heal you yeah gotta protect the thighs those thighs are a dangerous acid alright let's check them out now I love this part this is my favorite part oh yeah and then she has a you can get a new costume for Jian Yu too I think it's this one wait I have enough wait I like they're both really cute actually Oh,
this is hard.
All right, we'll give you your new outfit.
Wait, preview first.
I want to see it.
Oh, you can customize it too.
Oh, I didn't know that.
Wait, that's cool.
If you just won, like, parts of it.
Wait, what about this?
Yeah, it has customization.
Oh, that's hard.
Her outfit's so...
Her default is also really cute.
I think I like the pandas.
Oh, this one's cute.
Where are these?
Are these socks?
Okay, so she can have like tights, knee socks.
I think I like this.
I'm gonna buy it.
So yeah, there is a time limit.
Oh, also this outfit is discounted right now.
So you can get the new time-limited outfit right now from the same time as the event.
So it's like September 25th to October 15th.
Confirm.
But I gotta customize it.
I like this.
I'll have to buy this too.
I'll buy this.
I want this.
I like the panda is cute.
I think the panda is cuter than the red ribbon.
And then...
I'll buy this too.
I'm customizing my doll.
And then...
That's it.
I just wanted these two.
I don't need the whole thing.
But you can grab the box right now.
It's discounted at the moment.
So you can buy the Convergent Outfit Box for $4.99.
I guess it's like...
For $4.99.
That's pretty cheap.
Whoops.
I don't think...
Give me a sec.
Let me...
How do I Cancel I was like Wait that actually takes me to the credit card I Why don't you purchase it Alright Alright Jan you I should level you up too Uh wait Oops Let me make sure you're tanky as hell Level up Uh Begin training Training.
Alright.
Becomes strong for me!
You're my new girl!
The new girl in town.
Training complete.
Expand.
Oh, I didn't change my outfit.
It's alright.
We don't want to get the new outfit dirty.
Expando.
Alright.
Max you out.
I have currency for days!
Train to the top level.
Become the best that's ever was.
Alright, we gotta skip it.
I feel like it...
Wait, do I have more?
I do.
We're used everything!
Alright, nice.
And then more.
Simply the best.
Oh, yeah.
I'm just doing level by level.
Oops.
That's how much I love her.
level by the way.
Subject to commander level.
Wait, am I not strong enough?
No!
I'm not strong enough.
Weapons suit.
No, it's fine.
She doesn't need better weapons.
Chat.
It's fine.
Wait, where is she?
Oh, there she is.
It's okay.
We'll level up our level one.
I can change the gun, too?
Oh.
Weapon skin.
It's okay.
I'll make it look like a good gun
guys this is it looks like a good gun though it's all about how fancy it looks okay and then we'll we'll boost the gun we'll boost our gun we'll enhance it guys we're enhancing this alright
Yay!
Okay, so...
Calibrator.
Please use her actual gun.
She doesn't...
She hasn't earned it yet, guys.
This is her actual gun, but she hasn't earned it.
Okay?
We're gonna...
We're gonna wait until she got earned this gun.
who's retired
she has yet to earn the privilege of using of using her real gun it's not mean she got proof her words I'm not just gonna give her what she wants just cause she's new what kind of person does that set up for like the other girls chat the other girls will not be happy.
Alright, let's check her out.
Alright, what does she do?
What is she doing with that bear?
Oh?
Oh my god.
She's beating the shit out of it.
Okay, pose.
Deep sleep.
It's not creepy.
Guys, it's not... I want to make sure she's breathing.
I'm just trying to make sure she's breathing.
sure she's breathing I'm all right let's listen to her let's listen to see if she's breathing guys we're just trying to make sure just trying to make sure robots and robots oh oh okay she didn't know she didn't know hello there oh no She doesn't know.
She doesn't know.
I'm not being creepy.
I'm just making sure she's alive.
Oh, it's this.
Oh.
Kung Fu fighting.
Get it.
Oh, she's practicing.
She's practicing right now.
For the battle.
Oh, there's this.
What about the other poses?
Oh, she does Wushu!
Oh, that's cute.
Oh, she's like learning techniques, too.
Oh, she's very flexible.
Oh, there.
Oh, there, she's so hardworking.
If you keep that up, maybe you'll get your gun soon.
Better pose.
Oh, this is the Wushu one.
Yeah, really good balance.
Yay!
Good job!
I was like, wait, I'm in her- I'm actually in her room?
I thought I was just role-playing.
Should I clap from here?
Wait, where do I clap from?
Reset view.
Yeah, hands.
I was like, wait, I'm here?
She knows I'm here?
Yay!
I wonder if the hands only show up when I'm, like, over here.
How am I creeping?
I'm in her room!
She led me in to watch her practice!
How am I creeping?
Oh, gift.
Oh, yeah, I gotta give her stuff.
We gotta get the affinity up.
All right, nice.
Yay!
Affinity 2.
Oh, I can't.
Hold one.
Reach affinity.
Oh, I can!
There you go.
Confident ring.
Okay, how do I...
Wait, how do I get more gifts, guys?
How do I get more gifts for her?
Record 2?
Wish for a lot.
Oh, I have all of that.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Oh, that's it.
Okay.
All right.
Don't worry.
I'll be back.
Who is it?
Wait, where does the offense?
Oh, that's a cute gun.
I actually like that gun.
I'll be back.
Don't worry.
Mary Spear.
Where is it?
One moment please.
Oh yeah, this one.
This is a new outfit.
Aurora Shimmer.
Oh, it's cute.
Who is this for?
Daily login, claim.
That's a cute outfit.
Put on!
Oh my god, you'll get cold!
Why are you...
Jacket's not going to warm you up.
Look at your stomach.
You'll get cold.
You'll get frostbred.
You can't have your tummy get frostbred.
That's your best trade.
Now she cares.
Oh, is it here?
Oh, Nice.
Letter B.
I put through me a speed run.
Which one is it?
Oh, I can't.
I thought I could use this.
Do not use this to purchase.
No!
Now she'll never be my number one.
Wait, go back.
How will she be my number one?
Only through dailies.
No!
How will she be my number one if she doesn't love me?
Dorm shop.
Where's the dorm shop?
But this back shop?
So not here.
Oh, here.
Okay.
Oh, I have enough.
Alright, what does she like?
I don't remember.
Wait, which one?
Which one?
Which is, which is like, I give her stuff and then she loves me more.
Which is the best one?
Do you even love her?
She's new.
It's shiny.
it's it's shiny and she's new this one you barely have two is enough two is enough box v what is box v oh this one okay I can grab two wait can i not buy no okay what if i buy uh you know what tier tier three i don't know what that is but i'm using it all all right now that should be good all right uh yeah i got you something I got you this oh,
okay, um
That's I guess she doesn't love rocks, I guess She's like, why did you give me a rock?
Because I love you That rock Cost 500 grand
Who am I married to right now?
I know I'm married to her Alright Oh, wow.
I think I am.
Recollection.
I remember I was married to her.
Oh.
She was like...
Hello?
I think I'm not allowed to look at our memories.
I think she got mad that I forgot that we were married, guys.
I think...
I think she got mad.
She's like, you forgot our marriage already?
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I just needed a reminder.
I just needed to be reminded.
I'm so sorry.
Of course I remember, darling.
Of course, baby.
Of course I remember that I'm married to you.
And she's like, what's our anniversary?
I was like, look, I, oh man, I'm so tired.
I had a long day at work.
I...
You don't understand, baby.
I had a long day at work.
I think she got a little mad that I didn't remember.
But she doesn't know that I actually didn't remember.
I think I pulled through.
All right, let me boot it back up.
Give me a sec.
task i'll just force restart her
a long day of asking i didn't ask other girls for marriage i was just giving them gifts all right i was prepping it it's different
i it was i was just giving people am i not allowed to give gifts now is giving gifts a crime The giving gifts became a crime.
I just thought she did a really good job.
And I wanted to show my appreciation.
Anyway, guys.
If you guys want to check out Girls Frontline 2 right now, I'm not changing the subject here.
You can click the link that's pinned in my chat or in the description below.
help out the stream a lot and support the sponsor and also you get free pose and we all love free stuff oh my god i think she actually got angry that forgot the anniversary i'm i'm baby please i didn't mean it please let me let me back in come on let me back in girl i didn't mean it you know that right it was just all a joke it was all he he ha ha don't keep that on you if you come back please please don't leave please i don't want to sleep on the couch we can we can fix this
all right i'm boarding it back up i think i think come on come on baby come on let me in let me back it she really got it it's crazy it's actually crazy I just I just wanted to remember what her anniversary is it's not a crime dates I she took that out she was really it's not a crime
oh my gosh okay I'm forced quitting it again.
Guys, I really need to find a shrine.
I need to find a shrine.
It's so funny that this happened when the actual most likely girl to act this way.
Guys, I think she got mad.
I'm locked out of the house.
She actually locked me up.
I don't understand.
Why would she do this to me?
I didn't do anything wrong.
I wasn't I have so sure she has like three that you what how my bet I gave her so many things well not technically me giving her but like I was I'm there now I'm there for her now
you did I forgot one date and now and now I'm the bad guy yes it might be a very important day of her Like, I should get one pass.
We're married.
Marriage is a process.
The divorce came out of nowhere.
How could you do this?
How could I do this?
How could she do this to me?
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
I'll try one more.
I'll try, I'm gonna try and see if we can defeat things.
I actually even went, I even, I even went to task manager.
That's actually crazy.
I, I, everything was going so smooth.
And then I was like, oh, I forgot anniversary.
What is it?
Are we married?
And I was like, oh yeah, we're married, right?
and then she's like how could you forget we're married how no i could she won't let me boot up the game that's i can't believe it are we married she actually barred me from accessing the game now i'm gonna try one more time i'm gonna try not one more time i'm gonna try let's see all right frontline to run as that's it I'm bringing out administer you can't lock me out for I own this house I bought this place you can't lock me out forever I can verify it how do I verify it There's no verification here.
No, no.
I task managered everything.
All right, let me try again.
End task.
That's right.
It's her.
She changed the locks.
What?
She does not legally own.
I own the entire base.
Like, there's other girls there.
She can't do this.
Other girls live here, too.
Alright, run as I'm bringing admin powers in.
She got the keys to her house now.
Alright.
That's it.
Wait, I don't want to clear the game data.
Alright, resource integrity.
That's it.
I'm getting the big guns now.
I'm checking the resource integrity.
You can't lock me up forever.
You know what?
The moment I get back in, marriage, I'm filing for divorce.
That's right.
You want a divorce?
I'll give you a divorce.
I'm gonna marry someone else too.
Right after.
Don't tell her that.
Okay, guys, don't.
Guys, I need to get in first, okay?
Don't tell her that, though.
This is just me and the bros just coming up with a plan.
She's the one that, no, I'm gonna file, don't, don't tell her, no, guys, guys, don't tell her, no, no, no, no, she might, she might take everything, I, I, we, we didn't get a prenup, guys, and I think she has the better lawyer, so don't, don't tell her,
I said that, guys, I, please, I, this is all I have, don't, please don't tell her, please, please, yeah, you can't divorce, me.
I'm divorcing you.
Alright.
96.
It's getting there.
97.
We're almost there.
Alright.
Update another update.
What did she update?
What did she do?
Why did she update my game?
Oh, it's loading.
I got the loading bars.
the silly loading bars oh gluca please gluca gluca please let me in i don't understand what did i do wrong she knows she updated it to be what did i do wrong i don't understand she's she's updating the locks right now that's why it said update oh my god what did i do to deserve this please i have an idea clear game data that's right i cleared it what you gotta do now oh my god it's 47 gigabytes Oh my god.
That's right.
I cleared your memory.
I already did it.
It's too late.
It's 47 gigabytes.
She has no memory of today now.
Do not.
No, I did.
I verified it.
I did.
I did verify it.
But like, she's still locked.
She like changed the locks.
But yes, while we're here if you guys want to check out the game yourself and also have a very healthy relationship with your dolls please feel free to click on the link click to click on the link pinned in the chat and you too can have a very healthy relationship just like me and gluca just like mine
extremely healthy
Don't worry.
It was open.
It's an open relationship.
Like, why give me all these rings?
What's the point of having all these rings?
I'm just using what was given to me.
I have five rings.
It was already in my inventory chat.
It was a cheat.
No, that.
Why do I have five rings in my inventory?
What was I going to do with it?
They were the ones.
You know what?
They gave me five rings.
So what was I supposed to infer with that, guys?
It was not for storage, obviously.
I had a...
For five fingers, Stokey.
So you can put each ring on each finger.
Oh yeah, but anyway, yeah.
If you guys didn't know, didn't know, for the new people who are new here, You get 34 free posts for this new event and also, I believe, 120 posts if you are a new pillar.
And we all love free stuff.
Right, Kluke?
You love free stuff too, right, Klukei?
Klukei, I'm wearing divorce papers.
No, no, I'm divorcing her.
She's the one.
She's the one that locked me.
Who does that?
Do you wrong?
what what did i do wrong i don't understand i don't see how i messed up here chat i really don't i think she would you really yes i would like give me five reasons on how i messed up in this relationship look dates are hard to remember i think everyone would agree with me like do you remember your partner's birthday or anniversary you had five yes one for each finger what
see look see Jacob knows what I'm see look at that Jacob said of course not look see and then um uh and then bad horse was like hmm maybe so she's undecided And look at all these people that are saying like, no, you're right.
You're right.
No, like we're not supposed to remember everything.
Look at that.
That's shit.
I'm not getting one guy.
See, it's so true.
Look at that.
Hans on my.
Wow, so many people agreeing with me.
See, it's not one guy.
I read at least three different people.
at least three different people agreed with me so how can that be one guy if i counted one two and three oh yeah by the way since we're here waiting there's also like with the um with the new event there's also like a lot of limited time events so there's like i think there's like assault simulation and rhythmic tempo and rhythmic tempo is i believe it's like a dance rhythm game and then a new gameplay called phase clash where there's like rotating challenge mode and stuff um where if you guys want to like have a new challenge and it updates itself every week with different floors and everything so we're gonna check that check that very soon the moment my wife lets me in the moment the moment my wife lets me back in the house i'm calling a locksmith right now uh i'm calling the locksmith to let me back in we're just waiting on that how much to the download is done like two more minutes that's right Knew Kai two more minutes yes I still have she hasn't found anything yet not yet it's
fine I don't wait the locksmith is working very hard and getting me in I'm truly the lock so I'm don't worry she doesn't It's this was the last straw for me She messed up This was my last straw That's right I didn't do anything
I don't I just I don't understand What did I do wrong?
What could I've done wrong?
oh seven she doesn't know she doesn't know I stream she wonders why I like disappear for months and then come back but I told her like baby I just have like I'm just away on a business trip and so like they all like and I'm always so busy I work so hard to provide for us baby that of course I'm gonna forget important dates there's just so many dates to remember you know baby like I'm working so hard to support you
It's so gross
Welcome back, cheater
No, it's open It's an open relationship.
We all agreed.
You're actually giving me the ick.
I don't understand, huh?
I don't understand.
How am I the bad guy?
Does she know it's over?
I got five rings.
You're...
please okay here we go here we go the game has been downloaded oh
my god what did she do what did she do i don't understand what does she do what i actually don't know what she did How did she do it?
Research.
Okay.
Locate.
I don't know what she did.
Do I have to reboot?
I have to re- I wiped her memory and everything.
I wiped it off.
I have an idea.
Alright.
Before I reboot.
all right open file location wait okay let me double check can i boot anything else i got let me see so i can like boot up anything else just in case like i need a no is it me is it no it's not on steam it's not on it's uh It's the
It's the own It's the own app Okay I'm checking my Okay gross It has to be just gross Gross front line Yeah I'm using the launcher No it's not me I don't understand I don't understand It's not me, I swear.
It's not me, guys.
I have an idea.
If I delete all the data in this folder, then it should work.
Data.
That's right.
I delete your memory.
There we go.
All your memory gone now.
until the night you share about that and then i do resource integrity and then i'm redownloading the entire thing again i messed up i that's just i i'm redownloading the entire thing again i okay wait wait wait wait i got it i i have an idea i undeleted i still have my trash can Okay,
restore.
All right, I restore everything back now.
It's a lot of items.
It's 4,000 items.
I'm restoring everything back.
And I replace these files.
Continue.
Okay, wait.
And then what I do, I close this.
And then it's moving 4,997 items back to the original folder.
And then, Girls Frontline.
And then, Run as Administer.
And then I click Start.
You just deleted your old save.
How is I supposed to know?
I was just trying to wipe her memory.
So I can redo this.
So like she wouldn't know.
Like she wouldn't know.
I thought I could just wipe her memory.
So like nothing.
I didn't do anything wrong.
I don't think that's how that works.
Okay.
Guys, I might have to reboot my PC.
That might be the only option I have left.
I think she changed the locks.
I've tasked her memory is in the cloud.
Where is the cloud?
I gotta access it.
No, I actually, I, I task manager did like six times.
Kukai has taken everything that she took at my house.
She took my house and the dog.
Dad, no!
I'll be right back.
I have to reboot.
I have to reboot the PC.
And then maybe, maybe, maybe she'll forgive me.
I'll be right back, guys.
And my PC.
She took the PC too.
I'll be back.
I'm back.
It worked.
I had to do a system full.
reset like I restart I can't I I can't believe it I that's it you thought that's it Klu Kai that's it I'm so sorry will you take me back I didn't mean to I I'm so good God I'm so sorry please forgive me I didn't mean what I said I'm so Klu Kai please I'm so please I'm so sorry new guy I didn't mean to please please take me back don't do please I please bring give me back my dog and my PC I'm sorry I'm so sorry I didn't I didn't mean what I said earlier you're the love of my life all these other girls mean nothing to me i'm so sorry we can fix this i'll change i'll change just don't break my just don't steal take my pc again please she looks so disappointed because she knows she'll win she knows she'll win the divorce and i can't have her win the cat i can't ever divorce me,
guys.
I'll have nothing left.
She'll take everything.
She'll take it all.
She has a really good lawyer.
She said, please, please, don't leave me.
She's definitely got the better lawyer.
Don't leave me.
Please.
Please look at me.
Oh my god, please.
Look it.
Oh, wait, wait.
Here you go.
Please click it.
I'm sorry.
I used up all my gifts, too.
I don't have any more gifts.
I'm sorry.
Just don't break my PC again, please.
I'm sponsoring.
That's not for you now.
Alright, okay, so now that I know I've messed up and oh wait, I forgot you can oh, you forgot you could do that.
What's this?
Oh,
does she have like spots where I know that there's different animation depending on where you click, right?
Does she have that too?
Oh, she does.
Oh, it's so cute.
He's like, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We're just friends.
Don't tell.
Don't, don't, don't tell the cool guy.
Don't, I swear to God, please.
I need my PC right now.
Don't look, see, look.
I love you.
I love my beautiful web.
We're just friends.
I love you.
You just go back.
All right.
Because I don't want to be on the...
I don't want to be locked out of my home anymore.
I'm scared.
I'll give you your gun.
Here you go.
I'll give you...
I don't want to be locked out.
I learned my lesson, Klu-Kat.
You're so right.
Everything you do, you're so...
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
It's the motorcycle.
cycle.
Don't believe it.
Yokey's a lot.
Don't worry, Cluka.
I never betray you.
Please take me back.
When was I looking the side?
Oh, she looks at me.
Can I click anywhere?
Oh, I can't.
Click Cluka on the left side?
Like here?
Is it that?
I'm clicking her left side.
Or is this even about?
Oh.
Oh, she's like, come on.
On my invisible bike.
Oh, you're so smart, CluKat.
This is why.
Please don't divorce me.
I did.
I was clicking her left.
Or do I have to look at her left?
I guess we'll never know.
I love you, wife.
Here you go.
Thank you for taking me back.
I really appreciate it.
I promise I won't do it again.
I promise.
I'm sorry.
You're so right.
All right, let's go look at the new stuff.
Oh, front lines.
All right, front line survivors.
Okay, so this is a new event.
Oh, are these all the...
Are these all the...
Uh...
Um, the mini...
The new mini games?
Just some mine.
Wait, I'm sorry.
I'll probably...
I'll never do it again.
You're so right.
What is this?
Oh my god, there's a jump platform!
Wait.
We...
Oh my god, this is like throwback right now.
It's like classic.
Uh...
Like, to, like, classic games you play on your phone.
What's the highest score, though?
Wait, what's the...
Oh, I assume that's bad.
Yeah, this is, like, throwback for me.
Wee!
Super jump!
It is so easy.
I'm so good.
Oh!
This is so easy.
Wait, I'm so good at this.
I think it's just from all the experience growing up playing these games.
Alright, uh...
See, look at this is what I do in my free time.
Nothing else.
All I do is play this jumpy game.
See, whenever I'm, like, not at home, this is what I'm doing.
You guys can...
See, look, see, chat can vouch for me.
I have VOD proof.
but um but wait what oh no now i can't see oh i have grenade wait what am i gonna do a grenade i'm just jumping oh i'm just jumping i'm just like what am i gonna do with that okay so that just disappears oh shield but oh no no I thought the shield would make me like go past him.
I thought that's what it does.
I was like, I'm going to stand right in front of it.
So the shield, the shield would like guard me from it.
Okay, front line survivors.
In front line survivors, the doll fires automatically while the commander controls the doll's movement and determines where to aim.
Oh wait, is this roguelike?
Alright, Sabrina.
as well user.
Hey, why would I ever use... Wait, no, Sabrina has S damage.
S damage equals good.
Alright.
Is this Roguelike Survivor?
How do I use...
Oh, is this just my crosshair?
Oh, it is Roguelike.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, they know.
My one weakness.
repulsion field I will do buckshot I feel like that's like more damage oh no they know they know meal preparation all enemies have 20% chance of dropping food what is it depending on food she should have food each food also increases okay you're not getting your hitbox radius increase you're not because I refuse to let you be to let you destroy your like this,
Sabrina.
What if your belly pucks out of cover and you get shot?
You're not gonna become bigger.
It's, look, it says food will also increase Sabrina's hitbox radius by 0.1%.
But she's hungry.
She won't be hungry if she gets shot.
Okay.
More damage.
Oh, man.
I think, like, what's a little bit difficult is the fact that there is...
Oh, my God, I got hit.
I see.
This is what happens.
Imagine if she had even more.
More hitbox.
No win, no eat.
Oh, my God.
I got hit.
That's it.
I'm just...
All right, we try again.
I accidentally ran into that's it you might you just die I guess I'm sending you into the gulags uh buckshot that's like two bullets
the speedrun all right fine fine fine um we'll let her eat I'll guess I'll let her have like a salad Guys, I'm just doing it for her.
I don't want her to get shot.
My fire rate's always good.
I wonder how it...
Does she just get bigger on my screen?
Is that it?
She needs her pizza.
Give her her pizza!
Alright, there you go.
Fine, I'll do her a special.
She's so hungry, Doki.
You want her to...
Yes, yes, I do.
I do.
Whoever programmed her to have taste buds.
Like, how could you do this to me?
All you can eat.
When a boss is defeated, Sabira receives a bonus to regular...
You know...
You know?
Just let her eat.
She's just gonna nut.
We're just gonna feed her.
We're just gonna keep feeding her.
Eat that cake.
Might as well.
If I'm gonna be bigger, should be bigger too oh my god they shoot back wait they can shoot back they don't just gradually walk slowly towards me let her eat cake i am letting her eat cake what do you mean oh my god there's so many now um advanced weapon okay bullet count to each enhanced bullet generous a smile okay let's get that i feel like okay there it is i think that's what yeah that's field so it slows them down oh this is a little scary because i just have three hearts i assume i generate it though it says oh no it says like i get plus one hp but like when like when do i get it okay
attack knockback and where i'm eating yum yum yum yum yum okay oh my god i think the scary one is just a It's the one that guy with a gun.
Oh, whoa, whoa!
Why did you eat?
I let you eat and you...
It said you would give me food.
It said you would...
Okay.
Yeah, there we go.
We need this.
Oh my god.
We already...
There's so many people with guns now.
This is bad.
Okay.
Okay, the gun is scary.
Oh, and there's a pig.
Don't worry.
We know what to do with that pig.
We eat it.
Oh,
okay, we gotta go down, we gotta go down.
Oh my god, is it 240 seconds yet?
Oh my god, they're coming to me.
The bullets.
Oh, there's so much XP over there and I can't even get it.
Okay, uh...
Okay, I think I'm gonna keep my movement speed.
Oh my god, they're all coming in Please, I just need another heart I just need another heart, please
As long as the bullet guys don't get close to me Okay, that's fine I'm eating up all the Yum yum yum yum yum Yum yum yum Please Is it not 240 seconds yet?
Okay, there you go We're just, we're grabbing another HP here I don't trust myself Oh my god, there's so many bullets.
Here we go.
Uh, pirate.
Uh.
Bullet damage.
All in.
I don't even know what I'm...
I don't know if I'm upgrading the right thing right now.
As long as they don't shoot me.
Oh, please give me another heart.
Please, I need another heart.
Oh, please.
Okay.
We're okay.
Oh, large enemy wave.
Oh, wait.
Look at all this XP, though.
Yum, yum, yum.
I feel like maybe dexterity is so I can be a little faster.
As long as they don't shoot me, I'm fine.
Like, the walking ones are, like, so easy.
Oh, my God, they're coming.
a big boy.
I assume... Oh, he's dead.
It's that easy.
Every 45 seconds, movement speed is reduced by 50%, then creates a tidal fortress within a medium radius?
Oh.
Oh, okay, wait.
Sorry.
My meal prep is ready.
Um.
Please.
Oh, sorry.
My meal is...
My pre-cooked meal right here so i have to do that thank god thank god i yeah it's like putan uh oh it's like knockback oh that's it you can't get get me now oh wait i'm so slow why did i fix the title wave the title wave is not good the title wave is not good guys you think it's good but it's a lie it's a lie
It's a lie.
Tidal wave, not good.
I was so slow.
I was not ready to be that slow.
Emilia absorbs all drops.
This effect is triggered.
Hit bot radius.
Alright, there you go.
Balanced nutrition.
There we go.
We're starting to eat salads now.
Thank God.
She's healthy now.
We're on a diet.
Supreme.
Dorito's on a diet now.
There we go.
Because she's unhappy.
Well, it's not my fault that she had to go on a diet.
We'll get more bullet damage.
I feel like I'm so strong right now, so I don't really...
I'll just go all in and damage.
Because it's just kiting at this point.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my, thank God.
Okay.
So I had to, I had to let the person in.
Okay, we got, okay, we can, we can make, we'll make our, we'll make our entrance.
There we go.
That's, thank God.
I was a little scared because I thought he was gonna, she never would.
Well, it's not my fault.
She got shot in the stomach.
Like her belly poked out, so we had to put on, she, oh my God, it's literally all salads now.
It's all, it actually is all salads.
It's not my fault.
Her stomach poked out of cover and we realized there was a problem.
Shit.
Oh my god.
Oops, I got hit.
I was looking at chat.
I'm doing it for her own good.
She's so...
Let her have her bring her.
She's so sad.
And doing it is for her going good.
Okay, nice.
Oh, I got hit there.
okay very bullet damage range bullet size uh we'll do range so i can be further away that's good give her bigger cover when i send her out on a mission it's not up to me what size of the cover it is chat it's sadly i don't make that decision decision what is the point of the All right,
here you go.
Oh my god, this guy is so strong.
Okay, can I actually...
Nice.
Okay, that's easy.
Oh, there's so many of them now.
You all have guns now.
Bring your bullet damage.
Knock back all in a mile every bullet count plus three.
There you go.
Let's get more bullets.
So it's more range.
Yeah, now I can kill more people.
There you go.
I want to make sure that I have an escape here.
Go slow.
Like, I'm like, I thought it...
I thought...
Okay, clearly you guys all know I don't read.
But like, it sounded so cool.
It had like, oh my god, there's dogs now.
I don't know what this does.
I don't...
The description was so long!
I thought it did something!
The description...
You don't understand!
The description was so long!
Okay.
All right.
I want to grab all of this real fast.
I don't know.
Why am I so slow with it?
Okay.
For every 100 steaming burger, attack is increased.
Nice.
More attack.
Enough said.
Say no more.
I heard more attack and that's all I cared.
But I'm pretty good at this game.
oh my god not this again like it doesn't even i don't think it does damage i see more attack and i already know what i want guys get nice
oh my god all the xp is right there okay i gotta lead them i'm gonna lead them back here and then so i can pick up the xp oh wait this is a very big stadium i i wait a minute What was I doing?
The stadium is so big.
I've been, like, in this one area.
Congested in this one area for, like, 20 years.
What do you arrange?
So I can just walk around, like, this more.
Oh, hey, it's the pig.
The pig's back.
Oh, wait, I got hit?
By who?
Yeah, I was like, wait, there's more to this?
Wait, maybe I can...
and be greedy a little.
There you go.
More range.
So I can just run away.
Woo.
I wonder if 4 HP is like the biggest.
There you go.
Wait, I'm so strong.
I can literally just be like, do like this and be like, suppressing fire.
Oh my gosh, I got hit.
Never mind.
Don't stand still.
I don't know if you guys notice, but standing still is a very bad idea in this game.
There you go.
I have knockback, though.
Thank God.
Am I maxed?
No, I'm not.
Okay, that's fine.
I gotta grab some burgers.
We can max this out, actually.
I don't know if, like, I feel like damage will only be good against the boss fight, because I one-shot all of these guys in general.
Yeah, I, like, one-shot all of them.
I just need, like, more bullets so I can kill more people.
Yeah.
Just grabbing me.
Okay, now I'm greedy.
I'm too greedy.
Wait until the bunnies show up.
There's bunnies?
Oh, I won.
Yay!
Oh, the game was like, you did it.
Oh, so you have to survive to, like, 10 minutes.
I see.
And early level is maximum 10 minutes.
Oh!
So I just have to survive to 10 minutes.
Let's see.
Normal.
Oh, wait.
Normal?
That was normal?
Wait, in hands.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Basic attack.
Oh.
I don't have enough.
Wait, that was normal?
Reward, what do I get?
First try.
Okay, wait, we gotta do this again.
I'm sorry.
We gotta, I wanna unlock hard.
Okay, Endorus.
Okay, what does she do?
What is her, oh, I feel so weak.
What is her special power?
Let me fire it.
She's so weak right now.
Alright.
I want to see how hard hard it is.
I just walked into him.
Let's grab the HP.
We gotta grab the HP early on.
I was like, let's see how hard this is.
And I walked into him.
Oh my god.
I missed the two bullets.
I need more than one bullet though.
There we go.
Bullet.
size too.
Okay, nice.
Nope, it's still, never mind, it's still one bullet.
Oh my god, I missed her two bullets now.
I missed Sabrina's two bullets.
Her damage was S.
By the red upgrade?
Okay.
We're just going to lead them away so I can grab the upgrades.
This one.
Oh, is that, that's her special, right?
You might want to spec her red upgrades immediately okay so that's her special all right that's i understand now
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh i missed the two bullets I think she's out Oh she's ranged Never mind I forgot Sabrina I forgot Not Sabrina I thought she was a sniper Oh my gosh She's so weak Why are you so weak We need more damage We absolutely need more damage Yeah Her Beginning is rough I don't like it She does so little Like I did five shots Sabrina was like three I can't miss her I miss Sabrina She have all the food In the world world i miss it i didn't know how good i had it until it was god and let's grab the xp
attack is increased by arc reflex restore one shield after being attacked okay i'll get the positive
yeah sabrina was was like i didn't know how good she was until it was god
Sabrina was so strong.
She was actually so OP.
Like, I feel like it takes me 20 years to kill one person.
I'll grab the boss first.
Okay, I'll stack all her normal stuff first.
And then go... I need to get damage.
It takes me forever to kill these guys.
Oh my gosh.
This takes forever.
Uh...
Yeah, bullet... Wait, what's this?
Regular bullet damage?
Yeah.
No, she needs... She needs more damage.
Okay, now I one-shot them.
Thank God.
I was gonna say...
Feels like it's gonna take me forever.
It's fine.
I didn't need that shield.
Yeah, and more damage and more attack speed, I think, for her build.
Oh, my God.
They know.
They know...
They know what gets me...
survivors.
Tell Krookai, this is what I've been doing.
I have boss, Krookai.
I've been, I swear, this is all I've been doing.
I've just been playing rogue like survivors.
Don't you understand?
I swear, this is why I came home late.
I have boss.
Please don't knock me out.
This is why I was late to this.
because I got I was just I was playing a run like surviving oh my god I messed up I didn't see the minus 5 fire rate okay we need an upward fire rate now
shit oh yeah I fixed your fire rate because I selected the wrong thing I have a problem they're just so addicting I just like I just like seeing myself survive and then making different builds uh movement speed where's fire right oh here you go all right there you go and then we'll we'll fix it with damage later I don't even think she's good late game only because like only because like she does she Doesn't...
I was mowing people down with Sabrina.
At least it's not...
At least I'm not missing our anniversary dinner.
Which I still need to figure.
I'm too...
I'm too scared to click on the recollection thing.
I'm too scared to click on it.
Okay, range.
I'm worried KlupeCat is going to get mad at me again.
And she'll be like, you forgot.
I thought you said you remember our anniversary.
It's like, I do.
Of course, baby.
Of course I do, darling.
I was just... It was just...
Miss click.
Nice.
I need my shield soon.
Bum, bum, bum, bum.
Alright.
Oh, nice.
Oh, no, not nice.
I thought that was my shield.
I'll get bullet damage only because like I don't know I feel like I'm not mowing them down fast enough Am I one-shotting them I think I am no I'm not I am absolutely nope I need more damage I am Oh my god Sabrina would have wiped these guys instantly
I don't know if yellow is good for this game I think it's just like different sets Oh my god I need damage though Yeah, like, Sabrina...
Like, I'm not even one-shotting these guys.
Sabrina was one-shotting him.
Or maybe it's because I'm playing normal.
Wait, I forgot.
Wait, I did change the difficulty, though.
Maybe that's it.
Maybe it's because, like, they're...
They might be more tanky, because maybe I'm not playing on easy mode anymore.
That would make sense.
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no okay I might have to go back to Sabrina
it's bad I got cornered I'm just gonna I'm gonna I'm just gonna shoot from here I know I have a sniper so I don't I don't have to I need to go down you stop going they're so tanky they're so tanky I need to grab XP though okay these guys two shots okay at least I know These guys are two shots.
Oh my god.
Okay, nice.
A lot of XP here.
Oh, no!
No, okay.
I'm grabbing Sabrina.
Surrender.
I think Sabrina was the best for this.
Normal.
Oh, wait.
I got challenge.
Wait, how do I...
Wait.
Alright.
Alright, how tanky are they?
Not that bad.
Uh, long range, repulse by bullet size.
I want to make my shotgun a sniper shotgun.
Okay, they take two shots, so like, it's not that bad.
Alright, it's time to eat.
It's eating time.
Let her eat!
okay gotta be closer uh loot radius bullet size i'm grabbing the hp early on because i don't trust myself andoris was my champ i mean i don't think i've tried andoris yet but like i had oh my god your giant ass die you're all the calories went into your thigh and you got hit i can't believe Sabrina.
All the food went to her side.
She got it.
Nom, yom, yom, yom.
Okay.
It's okay.
God, I don't do anything.
I think I gotta keep eating.
Uh...
is a buckshot oh there's a buckshot there you go this is what clutched for me it was that and the the slowing thing does anyone remember what the slowing thing was called
okay we gotta put you on a salad diet soon there's too many cakes okay all you can eat there you go the tidal wave okay tidal wave actually was so clutch we're gonna try and get that
all right nice whoa oh my god that though that scared me i was like what happened oh no oh my god your stupid die your stomach poked out the cover can't handle you
is it this i think it was this right okay no that's from my end oh no oh no i can't see okay i generated on on my end it was the one that did like a load
uh repulsion is it this one
i don't remember i guess it was tidal wave oh i'm a little i don't know if i'm gonna be okay Oh,
it's not there yet.
Let's make ourselves a little pathway first.
Wait, why is he just standing there?
Is he okay?
He's just sitting there.
That's a boss fight?
Oh, he just makes it a little darker.
I was like, where are you doing here?
Let's move.
Okay, I want to be a little...
faster.
He's just standing there messingly.
Yeah, I was like, move.
You're in the way.
I want to grab another heal.
Om yom, yom, Got to eat my sandwich.
Om, yom, yom, yom.
Oh, there it is.
Splash ammo.
There it is.
This is what I wanted.
Oh, it wasn't this.
Oh, is it?
Oh, there it is.
Yeah, I got it.
This is the OP.
The OP build.
Oh my god, almost got shot at I got a little worry
There we go Yeah, that boss fight was very Underwhelming, I was like, that's it You just stood there You just stood there and let me get shot I don't think he wanted I think he gave up He gave up before we even started the fight Yeah Alright, I'm one-shotting everything So that I don't think I need damage yet Okay yeah whoever the other girl was I'm just one-shotting things now all right I'll grab this one just to be sure yeah he just gave up oh my god the bunnies oh the bunnies okay I know all right there they are that's I only win the bunnies nope there they are I still one-shot them so it's nice I just I am a a bit uncomfortable oh my god i'm so oh my god we need to get the salad upgrade we need the salad upgrade so badly you're so fast
fine we're fine the bunnies can't shoot a gun so like it's an improvement honestly like i'm less worried fire it i'll do fire it and then we'll do damage next That's Andorris?
Like, Andorris, like, like, like, look at how much I could do.
Compared to, like, compared to Andorris.
I literally one shot.
Andorris took me, like, five shots to kill one thing.
Like, be better.
That's fine.
I do so much damage that I'm not too worried.
Like, the bunnies, they may be fast, but, like, I have 2 million enemies in front of me.
So they got a stand in line.
Yeah, queue up if you want to kill me.
And number one is Klu-Kai.
Yeah, get behind Klu-Kai if you want to stab me.
Oh, nice.
Yum, yum, yum, yum.
Bullet count.
Okay, more bullets.
That's good.
That's good, like, it'll knock back, too.
Oh my god.
Where did he come from?
That was a drive-by.
Where did this bunny come from?
Oh, there's so many.
What happened to my barrier?
What happened to my bunny barrier?
Okay.
It's okay.
We're okay.
We're surviving.
There you go.
I was like, how did it get?
past them.
You have sadly cut the line.
I have a long list of enemies.
How did they cut the line?
Okay, oh, there's the title.
Okay, this one.
Every 45 seconds, movement speed is reduced by 50%.
Then creates a tidal wave fortress within a medium race that compels all enemies who are damp from entering.
Interrupts enemies with damp from charging.
All the subria are replaced by... Okay, you know what?
Let's try it again.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, yeah.
No, this is actually good.
I was gonna say, why am I so slow?
No, it's fine.
Being slow is fine here.
Actually.
That's actually pretty good.
As long as I don't get cornered when title wave is on, then we should be fine.
Okay, I wanna kill these guys in front of me a little bit.
I think we might need damage.
We're not one-shotting them anymore.
And I'm a little scared of that.
Oh, nice.
These guys are so fast.
It's crazy that she hasn't given me the salad yet.
She's like, no salad, no salad.
No salad.
Okay, fine.
Like, we're not getting the salad.
Okay, the bunnies are not...
Oh, there you go.
JK, it's salad time.
We're gonna put you on die.
it all right here you go oh my god he has a barrier now okay nice i should have needed that too because the more salad we eat the stronger she gets i know it's because she's angry at mirri or something
okay i just need to survive for three more minutes and then we win uh i'll get that Because we're not one-shining them anymore, which is a little scary.
Oh, oh, oh, remember when I said it.
This is okay as long as I don't get cornered?
It's okay.
If I keep going left, I can escape the corner.
See?
I escaped it.
And there's the XP stuff.
There you go.
It's fine.
Just kill him, too.
What?
He charges?
Okay, we definitely want more.
Oh, my God.
You can see on my top right how many... I ate a lot of burgers.
That is 55 burgers.
That's 54 burgers.
This is why you're on a diet, Sabrina.
You had 54 burgers.
That ain't normal.
Within 10 minutes, Sabrina.
You know how much that cost me?
Uh...
Bullet size.
Just make bigger bullets.
Oh, no.
Okay, that's fine.
Let her eat.
She deserves it.
Okay.
Uh, bullet damage.
So they can... She can one-shot.
Yeah, there you go.
Now I'm one-shotting.
I'm one-shotting now.
So now, now just get fired.
And she's a growing girl.
Brode enough, guys!
Yeah.
Well, I can one shot.
Okay, never mind.
Uh, we'll focus on fire right after.
Oh, no.
It's fine.
I can't get coordinator here.
I still have space.
I just would like to grab the XP, though.
All right, 30 seconds.
I just gotta survive for 30 seconds.
Woo!
Oh, we're almost there.
10 seconds, and I win.
Oh, man.
I'm glad it doesn't have unlimited mode because we'd be here for a while.
For now.
All right, let's grab the last food upgrade.
Oh, wait, it's been.
Oh, never mind.
It's past...
Does she know?
Okay, never mind.
We're still going.
I thought...
Okay.
Never mind.
We're still going.
Okay, my health is fine.
Okay, we got to survive for 10 more minutes.
Oh, this one's 20 minutes.
Okay.
Oh, there is unlimited mode?
Wait, do you have to beat this to get unlimited mode?
Oh,
that makes sense.
They want to test if you're a real gamer.
Oh, my God.
I need so much XP.
I'm so broke right now.
I've been...
They've been guarding the XP.
There you go.
Oh, no.
It's fine.
I have the heal thing.
It's okay.
Bye, bunnies.
Oh, no.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
I can make my own pathway.
I can make it.
Uh, okay.
Okay.
We just need more damage.
It's okay.
Not too cocky.
I'm sad.
I'm so sad.
At least I get more stuff.
Wait.
Are these gifts?
I put myself in the corner.
I told myself I wouldn't put myself in the corner.
Are these gifts?
All right.
See?
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Kuka, I would never do it again.
Here you go.
Oh, she looked at me.
She forgave me.
Guys, she forgave me.
Did you see it?
She gave me that look.
Okay, now, as a friend here.
Alright.
See, look.
It's just a friend gift.
Look, she forgave me, guys.
look at that i did it the side she she looked at me guys she looked at me that meant she forgave me i'm so happy she won't guys she won't do it again she's not gonna she's not gonna do it again guys all right phase clash all right so this is one of the new time event uh time limited events i believe where is phase clash is it the assault simulation wait the fiat admins to achieve victory the stage will be rated uh during battle you can open a pause menu i don't believe this is phase clash but let me see it's under events uh
Oh, it's in Niki.
Oh, it's in the top of the events.
Here it is.
Oh, it seems it'll be this one, right?
It's Boundary Push.
Oh, here it is.
This is.
Boundary Push.
So this is the new... Oh, there it is.
Oh.
Wait.
Low 55.
What level am I?
What?
Wait, how do I get to level 55?
I'm not high
enough.
I'm level 42.
Wait, how do you get to level 55?
That's a lot of...
Time to cry.
all right all right well it's okay i know what it is though i didn't have time to make a long stream
anyway so for those who aren't level 55 for those who are level 55 um Basically, you have to gather materials to upgrade the remoting pattern, and then the remoting pattern boosts the doll's base stacks and locks various power effects with special growth data.
So, just imagine.
Just imagine it.
And each area has, like, four floors.
So, and I think, like, they change the room a lot, too.
A boss will appear on the first floor of each area and it's guaranteed to drop one oval growth data So which is good.
Um, yeah, imagine And there's a lot of like commemorative items trophies and uh various qualities will drop as well Just imagine it imagine if I'm playing it right now and It'll become available each week and apparently there's like little easter eggs for week too so like if you guys want to explore a lot more you can get like little easter eggs too all right anyway i guess we'll just try we'll try assault simulation all right i believe i was looking at that earlier too there you go we can do at least we can do this all right challenge choose our dog um there you go kukai there you go see yeah uh I think auto,
because I don't know which skill it is.
Is this mode actually insanely hard?
How is this hard?
I just shoot the bots.
This isn't that hard.
I'm training.
Peek-a-poo!
That's right!
Do they shoot back?
First rule of robotics Don't shoot back
Okay Oh I have poison now
Okay I have unlimited ammo Come out Oh the black box is also targets Oh I didn't realize I thought they were just like props Okay
Like it has a happy face I thought he was a good guy Why?
He's smiling at me.
It's fine.
Peekaboo!
That was easy.
Okay.
He's like, Peekaboo!
I'm over here!
No, I'm over here!
Why do I have to shoot someone that smiles at me?
Wait, what?
Is he bad?
Wait, he has a face!
That's right, get down!
Get out of here!
Let's go shoot here.
She gets so much points.
She gives a lot of points.
Oh my gosh, she's still alive?
Okay.
We got this.
Wait, how long does this last for?
It's the last wave.
Alright, give me all the points.
Headshot, headshot, headshot.
Wait, it's unkillable?
Was it even worth shooting at her?
They're just trapped.
Yeah!
Easy.
I'm a winner.
Opens that.
Oh yeah, so each week.
Each week there's new
new challenges to try out.
Alright, now, now we can try out, we can try out the new character we pulled.
I just realized we never tried it out, so we should.
It's at each day, it's at each day.
My brain is, like, scrambled ever since Klu-Kai locked me out of the house.
Ever since Klu-Kai locked me out.
My brain has not, my brain has been so scrambled by her.
Yeah.
Every time I close my eyes, all I could think about is here.
Oh my gosh, I automatically click the refitting room because of it.
Yeah, Dianne Yuan wants to be with the electric team.
What do you guys want?
Wait, someone asked me to try something.
Boundary push.
Oh, wait, this one.
We try boundary push.
Can I try?
I put it in Replace Replace Oh my gosh She's so weak right now
Alright Do I have to bring in a full army What if like Does it have to be four people What if I just put Klu-Kai and Jiang Yu Wait, where's Springfield?
Yeah, I want to bring Springfield.
Strongly recommend.
Oh, so it's recommended.
It's just recommended.
Where is Springfield?
Oh, there she is.
I will replace her.
There we go.
Alright.
I don't know if like this is a good build but we can try.
My wife and my friends.
Alright so we all know this is a strategy game and I'm really good at that.
Oh wait it's not.
This party's not.
Hello.
What?
Oh shit!
I just wanted to say hi I just I just wanted to say hi I didn't know I wanted to say hi good bro okay I was just saying hi
Skip it.
Okay.
Shoot him.
Oh my god.
You don't do anything.
Alright.
Wait.
Gentle approach.
You see.
This is why she lied.
I just wanted to say hi.
You feel...
Oh now I do stuff.
Oh my skills.
Meteor.
Is that one enemy target?
I did.
Oh, wait.
This is easier.
Boom!
I set it up!
Oh, never mind.
Klu-Kai can wipe the board if used correctly.
Alright, just gotta...
Guess I just gotta use it correctly, guys.
There you go.
Nice.
I did it.
Okay, I might have messed up and, like, Send her.
Got her shot.
But that's okay.
Oh, spam force.
Boom!
Tornado!
Oh, this is our new- Oh, she's so fast!
Oh my god, wait, I got- Okay, we don't need to be too fast.
Did anyone caught the tornado?
Your turn.
Oh!
what's she doing shooting in the beach it's summer vacation oh my god I drowned him I drowned the robot all right use your special oh she's dancing oh my god I just sent a oh my god they're all dead yay I did it see gluca never got hurt oh I I forgot about this guy.
I'm gonna just shoot him, I guess.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
What?
What did she say?
Oh.
Oopsie.
Alright, now that I know what to do, what's this?
Crisis level.
Whoa, how did they know?
How do they know though?
I found three of the three.
Why is there a crisis level?
They don't know I'm here.
Okay.
We can do this.
Where's the- where's the ladder?
Alright, we can do this.
I can shoot from here.
There you go.
See?
I told you guys.
Oh, she saw me.
Look, I'm sorry!
I don't understand.
How do they keep finding him?
Wait, is this?
Watch this.
Wait, where am I going?
Ooh!
Oh my god, they're all dead.
And this is why you're my wife.
Pop.
Pop, oh, maybe I should have not popped him next to me.
Yay, I did it.
She's like, wait, I'm not done.
Let me stand, let me stand behind real quick.
Oh my god.
Oh, I did it.
Okay, that's what you guys said when you're like, yeah, Klu-Kai can basically kill everyone.
And then, let's open this.
Uh, where else?
I guess I can lock, yeah, unlock this area now.
Yeah, I'll do it two times.
I just wanted to see the, uh...
Okay, I can kill him, though.
Oh, my God!
Oh, I didn't see that guy!
Do you think he saw it?
Oh!
I didn't realize he had friends!
How was I supposed to?
It's okay.
Klu-Kai's got the motorcycle.
Yay!
Stealth.
Oh.
That's awkward.
It's okay.
I have healers.
Alright, Klu-Kai.
We gotta let other people have fun too, Klu-Kai.
Alright.
Well, okay.
This is a little awkward.
You know what?
Let's grab her in so, like, my wife won't get shot.
I feel like that might be ideal.
Yeah, I killed everybody.
Let's go.
All right.
Then my wife can stop getting shot at.
Okay, now.
Okay, wait, I got this.
All right.
I just have to shoot.
Where do I?
Where do I shoot?
Like, there's nothing to shoot at.
Like, he's gonna...
Wait, if I'm in the bush, they can't see me, right?
Okay, he saw me.
Guys, I think I did the puzzle.
You think I did the puzzle correctly?
Okay.
Lightning smash.
I wish I wanted to do the tornado again.
Confirm.
There you go.
Tornado kick!
Oh, that's so cool.
I guess you can...
Let's get closer to them.
You're all about the melee, right?
All right.
Wait.
Now we'll let...
Now we'll let Klu-Kai sweep the entire.
game yeah
oh wait I'm not done oh she's not done JK Kuka's not done she's done I'm done what she tells me I'm done yay we'll grab this we'll grab that and then we'll Grab this.
Anything here?
If I can jump down.
No, I can't.
I gotta use a ladder.
Safety first.
Oh, I guess I don't use a ladder.
I just jump down.
All right.
If I'm gonna jump anyway, why can't I just jump?
Like, I don't understand.
If I'm gonna jump anyway, just let me jump.
Okay.
Puzzle tab.
All right.
This is where I do the stealth.
Watch this.
Nobody's looking at him.
See?
I did it.
Oh.
You guys?
Okay, nice.
Okay, and then I shoot him.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
He was looking at him?
How was I supposed to know?
How was I supposed to know he was looking at him?
I was behind a box!
Oh, he survived.
Oh, okay.
That makes more sense.
What's this?
Oh, that's a cute move.
Okay, we're gonna...
Alright, we're not gonna kill everything for now.
Because I want Springfield to have a chance to fight.
Alright, Springfield.
Oh, never mind.
I mean, you can kill them.
Maybe what?
Oh, that was an elite enemy?
I can't believe she brought a pool to a war.
Thank you.
Alright, can I heal anybody?
Oh, it's Supernova Blackhull.
Let's get a Blackhull.
Let's just send a Blackhull in here, too.
Alright, Springfield.
It's time.
And summons wallet.
Four, three rounds.
I did this move already, so I want to try this one.
But I want to try this.
Wait, is this heal?
Oh, yeah, I got to heal Klu-Kai.
All right, get healed!
Don't worry.
My bird will give you heal.
All right, Klu-Kai.
Oh, I was going to say, Klu-Kai, you can sweep it now.
I know where I got.
I got Klu-Kai.
Dance time.
Oh, yeah.
Four also heals everyone.
Everybody.
Well, she got double the heals.
She got extra heals.
Oh, I forgot there was this one guy up here.
Wait, he has his own bird?
Oh, my God.
Oh, he dies from that.
Yay.
See?
She's extra healthy now.
Okay.
Go this way.
Grab some stuff.
Get here.
All right.
Is that the boss?
Oh, that's my bird?
Oh.
Can't see me.
Oh, can't see me.
Wait, what happens if...
Wait, does that mean I can, like, one-shot him?
Oh, no.
It's just so I can, like, kill his buddies.
No one's looking at you, right?
No, there is.
Someone's looking at him.
I don't know if I can stealth this.
Can I?
I mean, nobody's looking at him.
Because nobody will ever remember.
Oh, that's right.
Yoink, my, got your life.
No one's looking at him, so it should be fine.
All right, I'm going to get rid of the little guys first.
All right, now I can kill him.
Yeah.
Nobody's looking at him, too.
There you go.
Yoink.
My life now.
There's one more guy here.
Okay.
All right, now he's defenseless.
What you gonna do now?
You're defenseless now.
Are there sparrows?
There is.
Okay, I can shoot these barrels at him.
That's right.
Oh, he didn't see.
Oh, who did that?
Couldn't be me.
Okay.
Oh, there's no more.
All right, I just, I guess I'll just shoot him.
That's right, it was me!
It must have been the win.
Alright, Kuduka.
Go do your thing.
I just...
Oh, here.
Alright, Kuduka.
Do your thing.
Okay.
Yeah, I would- I'm wondering why would you place like an explosive barrel next to it.
Nice.
I did it.
Yay!
Reload.
Oh, reload.
Boss is dead.
Boss dead.
Yay!
Oh, we try to grab that.
Oh, I'm on fire.
Oops.
I'm a strategic genius.
My one strategy.
Use wife.
What, you have to rest?
What do you mean you have to rest?
I'm at 0% battery on my dolls?
Job done.
Two of you didn't even do anything.
Klu-Kai did everything!
I would understand if Klu-Kai had to rest, but two of you, two of you, was just chilling there.
He's just walking around.
The other two actually did stuff.
I'm tired from watching her.
all I'm saying is that Klu-Kai Klu-Kai may or may not have been doing maturity of the heavy lifting over there and also Jan Yu Jan Yu was also there too carrying all the gear Klu-Kai is just they participated and they were they worked very hard, okay,
Doki, everyone deserves equal amount of rest.
Yeah, one of them lied on in a pool!
She was fighting in the...
She just... She shot from the pool.
I don't understand.
I will give it to Springfield.
And Springfield had a bird!
The bird did everything for her!
Fighting Don't keep fighting in the pool Is very hard Jet swam Alright before Before we go Oh I didn't look at Springfield I forgot I want to wait Oh why are there other outfits though I realize Oh it was the dress or Um the other one Oh the dress is really pretty Alright since you're resting anyways Springfield.
I'm gonna check up on you.
She's resting anyway.
There's pondering.
There's there's that.
Wait, what is she waiting for?
What are you waiting for?
Me?
Are you waiting for me?
Wait, what does it look like?
Guys, please don't tell Klukei.
Please.
I didn't know.
I didn't know what she was gonna do.
Guys.
She's just, she's just crazy.
Look, look, I wasn't there.
I wasn't, technically I wasn't there, guys.
Technically, look, she's just rubbing, she's just touching air.
She's actually touching air.
Please don't lock me up.
Please don't.
Oh?
Oh, she likes it when I watch her read.
Oh, no.
Your chocolate.
Five second rule.
Don't eat the...
Wait, what is that?
Is that actually chocolate?
Whoa.
Oh.
Oh, sorry.
My camera's...
Oh, my God.
The sensitivity on my camera is so high.
Is that chocolate?
That's a coffee...
Why are you looking at a coffee bead?
What?
We have a lot of coffee.
We have plenty of coffee bean.
Springfield.
What?
We're not.
We don't have a shortage of coffee beans.
Yummy, yummy coffee.
He just really likes coffee.
Please, please.
I can get you as many coffee beans as you want.
Why are the other posts?
examining she got inspect the beans what is she looking at let me read your notes
whoa she's busy she's a very studious mom all right and then pondering oh we were here
oh yeah she is a coffee addict look she's drinking coffee she
She's just drinking coffee right now.
It's her carrot.
We're getting to know her.
We're getting to know her right now.
We're knowing her lore.
And then deep sleep.
She like changed sleep positions.
Whoa!
Oh my god, I feel...
I need to be in a corner real quick.
I- I- Please.
I forgot!
She was wearing a dress!
Oh my gosh, she was wearing a dress!
Oh, don't!
I forgot!
I forgot she was wearing a dress!
Okay, it's okay.
We're just- We're watching TV.
We're- we're watching TV with- with- with- We're just watching TV.
Look.
See?
I'm watching TV.
That's it.
I forgot!
I forgot.
She has...
I didn't look.
I knew it.
I looked at the corner.
I looked.
I'm...
I'm not free, freaky.
I actually said, no!
It was an accident.
I swear to God.
I swear, guys.
I swear.
It was all an accident, guys.
Wait.
Don't have to do my chat.
Oh,
my God.
Oh, my God.
The sky is so beautiful today.
The sky.
It's true.
Well, isn't it what a great, what great weather we're having.
Chad, what great weather it is.
All right.
That was fun.
I had a great time revisiting.
I had a great time revisiting girls' front line, too.
Excuse me.
I'm really sorry about the technical difficulties we had earlier today.
I don't know what happened.
I, I like, I just, I just forgot our anniversary and just wanted to remind her.
And she locked me out.
I don't understand.
I still hope, I still hope every, yeah, the wife kicked me out and locked me out of my, me out i just don't know i didn't i didn't know what to do today was today was a bunch of little a bunch of little surprises but i still hope you guys enjoyed watching a huge shout out again to my sponsor uh girls front line takes william for sponsoring me today if you guys want to try out the game check it out yourself uh please feel free to click on the link pin in the chat and in the description below.
You do get 34 free pulls for the event itself.
So, and also if you're a new player, you get 120 new pulls too.
So you get 120 free pulls if you're a new player and 34 free pulls if you are a returning player for this event.
So if you do this event, you do get 34 pulls in general.
So thank you again.
I hope you guys all had fun watching and liked my little adventure today in Girls Frontline.
Anyway, guys, as always, everybody, Stay hydrated, pot check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
For the member stream today, I will stream, I'm pushing it back 30 minutes.
I know we were supposed to stream 10 minutes ago, but I'm going to take a little breather, take a little break, and then we'll come back in 30 minutes for the member stream.
Hey, guys.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, everyone.
Bye.